[Music]
hello
i'm patty brennan the director of the
national library of medicine
today brings me great pleasure to honor
the national library of medicine staff
who are receiving awards under the nih
director's award program
although it would be great to be
together for this award ceremony
i'm happy to be able to acknowledge my
colleagues virtually for their
contributions
it's been a long while since we've been
on maximum telework
and i have to say that i'm impressed
with the quality and the dedication
of the staff of the national library of
medicine and how they have quickly
responded to the covet 19 pandemic
our work continues the work that we are
honoring today
is evidence that our staff often go
above and beyond
what is required in their daily jobs
we'll be giving awards
to individuals into teams in three
categories
first scientific medical second
administrative
and third mentoring the first award in
the scientific and medical category
goes to the advancing clinical research
through fire
team fire fast healthcare interoperative
resource
is a standard that allows for
transferring high quality
data for research purposes it's used
throughout the clinical care setting and
now this team
has made it possible for researchers to
use it my congratulations to
elizabeth amos clem mcdonald belinda
sito
and theresa zayas gabon the second award
in the scientific medical category is an
individual award
i would like to congratulate rodney long
rodney is a staff member who's
demonstrated exemplary
leadership in a wide range of technical
areas including engineering
and research investigations in support
of biomedical imaging
multimedia databases and machine
learning which supported breakthroughs
and
outcomes to cancer research across the
campus
in the administrative award category we
also have a
team and individual award to acknowledge
in the team award i'm acknowledging the
data science at nlm
team recognizing their outstanding
contributions
coordinating and delivering data science
training to the entire workforce at the
nlm
my congratulations to diane babsky peter
cooper
lisa federer and anna ripple
in addition i'm very happy to provide
lisa federer
with an individual nih director's award
dr federer has made outstanding
contributions across the nih
in developing and leading very creative
innovative programs for nih
staff both scientific administrative in
the use of data science for research and
for research management
our next award is in the mentoring
category this award is
provided to paulito fontillo for
exemplary performance while
demonstrating significant leadership
skill and ability in serving as a mentor
in addition to being a productive and
successful researcher
dr fontillo assumed the directorship of
the lister hill national center
for biomedical communications biomedical
informatics training program in 2013.
he has been a mentor himself to an
entire cohort of biomedical informatics
students of diverse scientific and
cultural background
and he's given lectures and conducted
didactic sessions
for these and other fellows across the
nlm and the nih
finally i'm delighted to acknowledge a
group of nlm staff
who are receiving an nih director's
award
along with their colleagues from the
center for information technology
here at the nih in recognition of
exceptional and sustained performance
coordinating supporting and
participating in an
in-depth gao information security audit
this team engaged across multiple nih
organizations
congratulations to the gao information
security audit team
including our nlm colleagues ivor de
souza
darning kung mike simpson alou
affalaju and jacqueline peltekian
congratulations team i want to close by
congratulating
all of my nlm colleagues who've received
acknowledgement today under the nih
director's award
and all those who've supported and
ensured that the nln's products and
services
and science continues to progress
thank you and my best wishes